résolus que par un ensemble de mesures
et la crise ukrainienne dépend pour
beaucoup de la façon douce évoluent les
relations entre la fédération de russie
et les pays occidentaux
mené par le washington
c'est pour ça que dès le début
l'initiative
heureuse qui était que nous étions prêts
à discuter avec eux
et un propos desquelles les américains
se sont super souvenu des idées
précédente mais nous le ferons
uniquement dans
l'optique d'une réponse à notre question
prioritaire qui déprime c'est à dire la
fin de l'extension de l'otan vers l'est
et le retour à la configuration de
présence de l'otan sur le comptant
continent européen à partir de la
position de 1997 et dans le cadre des
accords qui avait été conclu entre la
russie longtemps et bien entendu
notre appel ou plutôt notre
revendication
d'expliquer pourquoi les documents qui
ont été signés au plus haut niveau
disant qu' aucun pays n'a su rsa
sécurité nous aux dépens de celle des
autres mais nos collègues refusent même
d'expliquer
ce qu'ils avaient en tête quand leurs
dirigeants signait ses documents et
pourquoi aujourd'hui présents
indépendamment de cela ils n'ont pas
l'intention de remplir leurs obligations
monsieur poutine sur votre ordre j'ai
adressé ces documents à washington
monsieur antony blinken le secrétaire
d'état m'a appelé il m'a dit qu'il avait
pris connaissance de nos documents et
qu'il était prêt à
une rencontre pour pouvoir discuter
pour exposer sa réponse est peut-être
traiter de questions supplémentaires
avec votre accord donc nous avions
prévue de cette semaine à genève le 24
février nous allons parler d'eux des
questions qui sont proposés
nous sommes en contact avec nos
collègues et au niveau du ministère des
affaires étrangères nous allons
poursuivre le travail là dessus je vous
remercie
donc avec mes collègues justement j'ai
parlé à ce sujet avec les collègues
américains et je dis que là le cren
nous n'avions ils m'ont dit qu'ils
n'avaient pas l'intention d'adopter
intégrer le cren dès demain et qu'il y
avait même un moratoire mais il
considère que le crâne n'est pas prête
aujourd'hui
nous
comprenons que ce n'est pas une
concession à notre égard mais c'est
plutôt la réalisation de vos de vos
plans donc ça veut dire que le cren est
en cours de préparation pour son
adhésion alors c'est quoi ce moratoire
donc c'est quand même un mouvement en
direction de nos îles d'hyères nous
avons parlé deux fois avec le président
français
même la nuit donc aujourd'hui jusqu'à 2
heures du matin c'était aujourd'hui déjà
il m'assure que la position américaine à
quelques changements
mais en quoi consistent ces changements
il n'a pas pu me répondre
donc je suppose que il faut commencer
par comprendre
ce que sont ces changements s'il existe
parce que votre collègue au contraire
voire même peut-être siens indique il
n'y avait il n'y avait pas de changement
sur la question de l'extension de l'otan
et
en particulier concernant le cas
si on se réfère aux nombreuses
publications dans la presse dans la
presse occidentale
et notamment de la publication de
documents secrets des années 1990 et
il aurait dit que soient avec nous soit
entre eux il n'y avait aucune intention
des pays occidentaux quand ils en
parlaient en cercle restreint pour
l'extension mais monsieur sollten
berquier aujourd'hui secrétaire général
de l'otan
re refuse
rini les documents qu'ils sortent des
archives et qui viennent d'être publiés
et malgré tout cela malgré toutes ces
publications il il dit ce qu'il dit hors
de question de d'affaiblir leur
politique d'extension ils ont dit après
plusieurs fois que cette politique
n'existe pas mais qu'il est possible que
dans les accords de washington avec
l'accord de tous les membres de l'otan
de proposer à tel ou tel pays d'adhérer
à l'otan sous deux conditions première
condition si elle satisfait à ses
critères d'adhésion et deux si elle
ajoute de la sécurité à l'alliance
atlantique mais ce deuxième point cris
de ce deuxième critère est complètement
ignoré depuis longtemps en ce qui
concerne quelles sont les nouvelles
idées que peuvent nous proposer les
américains et leurs alliés nous partons
du fait que le président comme vous
l'avez dit au président mâcon faut
comprendre ce que les américains ont
envie ici et nos collègues français nous
donne une telle information qu'il ya
une évolution et que dois je suis on ne
peut parler avec nous mais comme vous
l'avez dit avec les présidents macro
hier
et avec le ministre des affaires
étrangères
de français j'ai demandé moi que
monsieur le drian nous donne au moins
quelques éléments pour comprendre
concrètement
en vue oui c'est ça je vous remercie
asseyez vous je vous remercie
donc mettrie causa que maintenant va
intervenir je lui ai demandé
de nous faire un point de vue de tout ce
qui se passe sur en matière de la de
règlement de la situation
et après je demanderai aux autres aux
autres membres du conseil de sécurité de
s'exprimer
à partir de la situation telle qu'elle
est aujourd'hui concrètement dans les
républiques de donetsk est lougansk
monsieur cause est à vous
monsieur le président chers collègues je
vais pas vous est plus élevé que
beaucoup de détails de ces sur ces
négociations je dirai simplement qu'une
chose
un peu plus forcément on voit
aujourd'hui clairement
que
les
le cren on est absolument utile pour les
partenaires occidentaux c'est simplement
un prétexte pour pouvoir imposer à la
russie quelque chose il considère la
russie comme une
commune parties au conflit
et donc ils veulent infliger des
sanctions économiques
à la russie pour le downtown basse
donc vous savez que le soutien ces deux
pays c'est un coup énorme et ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui les statistiques qu'on
a
montre en tout cas
nous avons peut-être toutes les
informations en temps on y met donc en
en plus que
bousquet recrudescence
[Musique]
aujourd'hui il a la situation est très
changé dans le donbass il faut
comprendre le contexte économique aussi
très peu de chômage il ya plutôt un
manque de main d'oeuvre dans london
basse il ya eu la délivrance de
passeports russes une grande partie de
la population donc si on parle de l'ecc
rennes on voit qu'aujourd'hui très bien
london basse est absolument aucun
intérêt pour le cren et pour les pays
occidentaux y aurait la question
rhétorique de savoir si commun il
reconsidère la possibilité de réintégrer
le donne basse dans le cren et quand on
en parle avec sony comprend on voit ils
ne savent même pas quoi répondre à cette
question en ce qui concerne
le dong basse
c'est peut-être même pas nécessaire
d'expliquer les raisons
non mais parlez nous vraiment du
processus de négociation autour des
accords de minsk où on en est où
aujourd'hui on en est à zéro depuis 2015
je tiens à rappeler que l'ensemble des
mesures de désaccord de minsk le
dialogue
pour attribuer un statut particulier
noces devaient commencer dès le
lendemain du retrait des armes lourdes
cela avait été fixée le 28 mars 2015
donc ça devrait commencer tout de suite
immédiatement pour que à la fin de
l'année 2015
il puce déjà entrées en vigueur au sein
de la législation ukrainienne le statut
particulier d'audace or il ya toujours
eu des reports et ensuite il devrait
donc y avoir des élections et après il
devrait y voir la transmission du
contrôle sur la frontière cela c'est ce
qui devait être fait en 2015 le crâne
tient secrets tous les détails de ces
questions là il n'y a pas de
négociations directes
au niveau des
des entités territoriales des
municipalités municipalités de l'île
devait donc avoir une délégation de de
pouvoir et aujourd'hui on voit qu'il
n'ya absolument rien parce qu'ils ont
peur d'un précédent c'est-à-dire que si
on donne un statut particulier ou d'une
basse avec la possibilité de choisir la
langue utilisée
et avec un an plus une influence de
délégation de pouvoirs pour certaines
autorités locales ça veut dire que ils
ont peur que cela s'étende à l'ensemble
dans le crâne et ils ont peur de
l'autonomisation de saintes un
territoire en ukraine
dont ils ont convaincu toute l'ukraine
que
les discussions de minsk où les
discussions
et c'est à dire que publiquement ils
déclarent leur attachement aux accords
de m mais après ils disent aussi
publiquement que que ces accords 2000
sont
une corde autour du cou c'est pas
possible voilà here j'ai parlé une
nouvelle fois donc je dirais que le
président collègue président français il
a affirmé que les autorités ukrainiennes
était prête à remplir les accords de
minsk mêmes quelle est la portée de
nouvelles idées constructives pour
l'exécution des accords 2006 notamment
en matière d'organisation d'élections
et notamment c'est avec en conformité
avec le plan de l'actuel président
allemand steinmeier
donc si on regarde aujourd'hui au fond
les accords de minsk ces documents qui
sont
proposées aux dans le groupe de contact
de format en normandie c'est écrit noir
sur blanc
voilà dsk il va falloir réchauffer tout
tous ses écrits avec un fer à repasser
je sais pas mais le ils disent la russie
la russie et une partie au conflit je
dis d'accord mais un cruel
et alors pourquoi vous dites que la
russie ne remplit pas ses obligations
on ne sait pas ils disent qu'on fait une
analyse son choix d aider les français
les allemands à comprendre
j'ai rédigé le mais les français les
allemands disent 'peut-être que la
russie va elle-même
rédiger sa donc la question voilà
qu'est ce que l'eau de basses ne fait
pas qu'ils devraient faire d'après les
accords de minsk parce qu'il y avait la
question de position désarmant nous ne
savons pas ce que fait pas le nom basque
nous ne sommes pas capables de le
formuler formule est l'oeuvre main
c'était qu'est ce qu'ils savent pas
c'est à dire dans le cadre des accords
de risques que le dôme bas ce
qu'est ce que le dôme bas cela fait
donc il parle des responsabilités de la
russie et de certains
expliqué donc il ya le point 9 chez les
points
11.12 ses marques et que les décisions
doivent être prises dans le dialogue
avec
via des consultations avec ses
république
eh ben voilà il considère que
à l'encontre de ce qui est écrit
mais même pas la peine de prendre un
dictionnaire ressembler pour voir que
ils disent que ce n'est pas une exigence
de que kiev ait un dialogue direct avec
les républiques de l'uden basse pour
leur ego c'est à dire que ce qui est
écrit en matière de dialogue il
considère que
ça ne signifie pas un dialogue direct
voilà et hier monsieur mac on vous a dit
qu' il était nécessaire que ce dialogue
se fasse
strictement dans le cadre de l'accord et
et sous le le contrôle de l'eau et se
et du contact d'un groupe
or c'est un problème qu'ils inventent
complètement ce problème il n'existe pas
toutes les propositions du donbass
n'aime pas le groupe de contact par
l'ouest
les représentants de l'ukraine
détourne la tête qu'on les représentants
de donner s'ils gagnent pas ils
s'écoutent pas
et alors ils disent si la russie dit
quelque chose nous répondons et quand la
russie demande pas quand est-ce que vous
allez signer c'était la dernière fois à
bâle
et le cren le lendemain à organiser une
crise de panique
et
dit qu'il ne faut pas faire de
d'ultimatum pour que
le cren face des amendements sa
conscience je vous comprends bien c'est
à dire que bon direct les autorités de
kiev ne veulent pas de discuter en
direct avec les autorités de donatello
grasses elle veut le faire dans le
dialogue avec la russie et dès que la
russie propose
des mesures concrètes pour règlement
pour régler cela en fonction il accuse
la russie de s'ingérer dans les affaires
au créneau oui c'est exactement ça
ils veulent que la russie ils veulent
nous obliger à région et après ils nous
reprochent de danger nous accuse
d'ingérence
donc ils disent que il faut comprendre
les accords de metz de telle façon que
ce ne sont pas les républiques qui
doivent manifester
une initiative mais les autorités de
kiev qui doivent
émettre des propositions en matière
d'exécution des accords de main dessus
donc c'était la dernière proposition qui
date du 10 février à berlin donc c'était
une sorte de cri thynnus puisque la
législation ukrainienne en matière de
d'adoption donne d'amendements ne dépend
que d'eux
ce n'est que du ressort de l'ukraine et
donc il y avait des propositions des
propositions qui était délirante de la
part de l'ukraine si le donne base
propose des alternatives est ce qu'elle
voit un disque de ils baissent les yeux
ils disent on ne sait pas
donc on voit tous que toute cette
tactique ces derniers temps qui est
maladroite qui il est en vente sur place
de nouvelles dispositions
est ce la signifie que les propositions
et craignait de
l'amendement alors dans leur
constitution ne peut ça ne peut être que
qui peuvent le faire ils refusent de
discuter avec les gens du donbass
et curieusement tout d'un coup la france
a soutenu cette proposition alors sur le
point clé désacord mines selon lequel
tous ses amendements notamment dans la
concession doivent être validés avec
donetsk lougansk sont ignorés par le csa
non seulement c'est ignorer mais en plus
ils inventent toutes sortes de schémas
compliqué
je dis que c'est du crétinisme juridique
donc par exemple les 10 nous ne parlons
avec personne
dans le groupe de contact si la russie
propose quelque chose on va voir comment
région comme je voulais dire non
seulement d'agir comme je voulais déjà
raconté et ensuite l'eau et se doit dire
que c'est dans le cadre de cette boîte
noire du groupe de cons contact donc ce
sont des procédures complètement à
vendre alors attendez je encore une
question clé dites moi à moyaux
collègues votre avis
les autorités de kiev vont remplir les
accords de minsk où parut
selon l'évolution
qu'on connaisse jusqu'à présent des
événements non ils ne le veulent pas
ils ne veulent ni minsk naissant les
accords de mais ce qu'ils ne veulent
restituer ce restituer le territoire de
damas je voudrais répondre aussi à votre
question sur la question de rattacher le
don de basseau pas
alors c'est une question une
problématique grave et alors
alors écoutez attendait pour l'instant
on va voir ce limiter votre votre
intervention sur
le déroulement du processus de
négociation dans le cadre des accords de
musique est votre évaluation de la
perspective
on a compris que ses perspectives
n'existe pas justement d'après votre
intervention mais en tout cas les
perspectives d'évolution de ce processus
de discussions dans le cadre des accords
de miss je vous remercie maintenant je
voudrais demander
le directeur du fsb
mais c'est bortnikov de parler de la
situation telle qu'elle est sur la
frontière et notamment
ceux que les gardes-frontière voit les
mouvements de population depuis l'autre
territoire sur notre territoire c'est à
dire la situation à la frontière
monsieur le président nous voyons une
dégradation de la situation
sur le territoire des deux républiques
de donetsk est lougansk
donc on voit une augmentation du nombre
de tirs et cela présente constitue une
menace pour la population civile
ensuite il ya cette sûr qu'on en a vu
donc le mouvement de réfugiés qui se
dirigent vers la frontière de la russie
est aujourd'hui
deux heures du matin de donetsk est
lougansk
on avait
plus de 60000 personnes qui avaient
franchi la frontière de la fédération de
russie c'est ce qu'on dit qu'est ce ce
qu'ont indiqué les gars frontière ils
sont en contact permanent avec nous avec
les réfugiés
première chose deuxième chose
donc l'identification des tirs provenant
des groupements militaires russes autour
de lougansk de donetsk et les on a noté
des cas où des obus tombaient sur le
territoire de la fédération de russie la
légende de rostov et nous avons donc eu
avec le comité d' enquête de la
fédération de russie nous enquêtons sur
ces cas cette nuit
deux groupes de sabotage
ukrainien militaire ukrainiens ont
atteint la frontière de la fédération de
russie dans la région de lougansk est
prêt de mario paul et au cours de
combats nos gardes frontière soutenu par
l'armée russe ont détruit les deux
groupes de sabotage
dont un militaire ukrainien et ans est
prisonnier de l'armée russe
donc la situation de notre côté est
stable nous suivons et nous avons des
renforts des renforts du côté militaire
et nous travaillons aussi avec le
ministère de l'intérieur et la justice
je vous remercie
le ministre de la défense je sais que
vous suivez la situation
alors votre évaluation s'il vous plaît
cher monsieur le président chers
collègues si on parle de l'évolution de
ce qui se produit aujourd'hui
on a eu plus de 200 tirs en direction
de la russie avec des tirs de canons et
de mortiers le résultat de des actions
deux groupes de sabotage et de tir
direct la ville de donetsk
se trouvent presque privé d'eau en tout
cas dans 90% du territoire de la ville
ils se trouvent privés d'eau à lougansk
c'est des privations de gaz et tous les
gens qui étaient dans la zone
le long de la du fonds ont dû évacuer
ces zones à une part de la population
qui est obligé de travailler sur place
continuent et donc il ya des entreprises
qui ont un cycle de production en
continu et aujourd'hui justement
un parc
d'autobus
un conducteur de un employé de mines a
été frappé et au cours de la nuit
dernière sur tout
le sur tous les secteurs
il y a eu un grand nombre de
bombardement
est en tout cas tel que nous voyons la
situation est comme le rapporte les
spécialistes
c'était justement un objectif se c'est à
dire que les feux qui ont été les tirs
ne sont pas sporadiques ils sont visés
ils sont ciblés
et je peux rapporter que on a des forces
concentrés au niveau de la frontière
du côté
à peu près 50 mille militaires
qui sont concentrés sur les frontières
de donetsk est lougansk
après vos discussions que vous avez eue
sur les mesures de sécurité
et donc l'armement lourd devaient être
retirés de la ligne de contact à une
distance de tir tels que ça ne puisse
pas touché des localités or aujourd'hui
le on constate le retour de ces
armements lourds le long de la ligne de
contact
et donc on nous avons constaté la
présence de plus de 50 mille militaires
d'ukrainiens sur les armements
il ya des systèmes d'autres cas eu
trois cent quarante un chat plus de 250
véhicules blindés
vingt huit cent vingt cas non
160 lance-roquettes et notamment smerch
et je ne peux pas négliger non plus que
je ne compte pas les bataillons
néo nazis dont il a été très souvent
question et et qui pour des raisons tout
à fait objective
sont mal gérées par les autorités
ukrainiennes et parme et par les
commandants militaires et donc ils
agissent comme bon leur semble et je
pense que c'est de ces deux groupements
là que proviennent les les groupes de
sabotage qui ont essayé de pénétrer en
russie et toutes sortes d'assos
d'attentats notamment la destruction de
transformateurs la destruction de
conduite de gaz ou le ménage une voiture
dans de nature donc que les autorités de
l'ue 27 et daunay 2e attire l'attention
de la russie sur la déclaration de
du président c'est lenski disant qu' ils
veulent leur île le cren voudrait
redevenir un pays nucléaire j'ai pas dis
puissances nucléaires mais pays
nucléaires cela signifie que pendant les
longues années de la période soviétique
quand le pays était parti de l'ua cesse
donc il y avait des possibilités donc de
créer des armes nucléaires mais aussi
des vecteurs et on peut rappeler aussi
que il y a des armes nucléaires
tactiques
qui était qui sont en allemagne et qui
peuvent tout à fait apparaître ici en
ukraine donc j'ai parlé de l'armement
tout cas eu
on sait très bien que cela peut être
utilisée il ya l'armement il ya les
technologies à des spécialistes
qui peuvent avoir la possibilité
pensons-nous
qui ont travaillé avec l'iran ou
la corée du nord et qui ont participé
notamment
pour que ces pays soient
armés de façon nucléaire
après il ya aussi cette composante des
bataillons nationalistes ukrainiens et
ce n'est un secret pour personne que ces
bataillons finalement une influence sur
telle ou telle situation
dans différents endroits en ukraine je
pense que cela est lié avec ces
extrémistes et leurs appels
à l'adresse de donetsk et de lougansk
mais aussi à la base de la russie donc
la tension est à son comble dans la
situation est depuis le 14 février on
nous constatons un renforcement une
multiplication
des
de toutes les étapes si l'on considère
toutes les étapes possibles de la
préparation un combat on peut voir que
nous en sommes aujourd'hui aux étapes
les plus avancées donc on peut assister
à des
provocations ou à une action armée de
planifier
ça peut être le changement le
déplacement des armes lourdes de
l'artillerie
notamment des changements des fréquences
radio
et c'est peut être aussi
tout ce qui est lié nous y est
essentiellement
aux tirs sur la ligne de contact on a là
il ya longtemps qu'on n'avait pas eu ça
hein ce point et là nous en sommes
on peut comparer à ce qu'on avait en
2014 2015 je vous remercie
chers collègues
sur la question des négociations
de
sur le dos de base je pense que vous
comprenez très bien la situation
aujourd'hui nous voyons que cette
situation a été bien
décrite par
notre mise à la défense un par les
diplomates par le fsb est longue c'est
une question qui se pose aujourd'hui il
faut que nous considérions ventes 7
l'adresse envoyer par la douma au chef
de l'état
qui porte sur la reconnaissance de la
république populaire de donetsk et la
république populaire de lougansk
les menaces et les chantages de nos
collègues occidentaux nous les voyons
nous comprenons pourquoi en quoi cette
décision est liée
nous voyons cette situation dmitri
medvedev à vous
monsieur poutine
je vous avais caractérisé donc la
situation que nous constatons notamment
en matière de sécurité pour notre pays
c'est à dire les tentatives de l'otan et
de des états unis de
retard reclasser les cartes du monde
pour avoir un tableau à leur avantage
et nous mettre dans une situation
extrême et ce sont les fameuses lignes
rouges dans président a parlé à
plusieurs reprises et nous en avons
parlé beaucoup dans différentes
conférences si on considère la situation
des républiques populaires de donetsk
est lougansk nous comprenons très bien
que en tout cas pour moi c'est très
clair je pense que c'est confirmé par
l'intervention de mes collègues ces
territoires
sont inutiles pour le cren est
en tout cas c'est une monnaie d échange
qui sert
et cette statue du donbass et 2 cm temps
n'attendent depuis de nombreuses années
n'attendent aucune aide de la part des
autorités de kiev est la seule chose
qu'ils reçoivent ce sont des
bombardements des privations de droits
élémentaires et dans l'ensemble tout ce
qui se produit
fait que on peut comprendre que
l'ensemble des mesures
qui ont été validés dans
les accords de mills ne vont pas être
rempli parce que même en présence d'une
pression d'autres pays comme la france
l'allemagne
très probablement les autorités de kiev
en tout cas avec le président actuel de
ces accords ne seront pas
ne seront pas validées et ce que vaut ce
président c'est sa réélection donc ce
n'est pas dans son intérêt de respecter
les accords qui a été conclu
et lui comme son secrétaire
déclare directement que ils ne veulent
pas signer ces accords et ensuite il
continue à raconter n'importe quoi
et on en des déclarations
régulières qui sont dites à propos des
accords de metz nous sommes aujourd'hui
de nous sommes devant un dilemme très
grave ce qui c'est à dire la
reconnaissance ou pas de ces deux
territoires qui sont prêts
et qu'ils veulent cette reconnaissance
et c'est les déclarations qui est en
fait à notre adresse de même que notre
parlement a proposé en arrêter et même à
adopter cet arrêté je me souviens très
bien l'année 2008
je peux parler de l'expérience que
j'avais puisque à ce moment là j'avais
dû prendre une décision qui était
difficile puisque j'avais reconnu
l'ossétie du sud et l'abkhazie comme
sujet du droit international en tout cas
l'ordre donné le caractère d'état au
niveau international je peux entrer dans
les détails maintenant ici il ya
beaucoup de difficultés particulières
mais en même temps on voit très bien que
cela a permis de préserver la vie de
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
vivent sur ces territoires
et c'était une leçon évidemment pour
l'otan
pour un certain nombre de pays
occidentaux
n'est qui était qu'
il faut pas agir de cette façon avec la
fédération aussi aujourd'hui la
situation est bien plus compliquée et
d'un autre hôtel et peut-être même plus
simple elle est plus compliqué parce que
l'ampleur d'un conflit potentiel est
incomparable par rapport à ce que nous
avions en 2008
et ça c'est très très clairs notamment
d'après l'analyse qui vient d'être donné
par le ministre de la défense d'un autre
côté
pourquoi c'est plus simple pour nous
parce que à l'époque on ne savait pas
quelle serait la réponse quelle serait
la réaction
est aujourd'hui la situation c'est que
on parlait avec bush
aujourd'hui on connaît la situation on
connaît toutes les difficultés
toutes les propositions de sanctions
qui ne cesse d'être respectées et
on sait que cette pression votre maximum
mais on comprend aujourd'hui réagir à
cette pression donc en 14 ans
on n'a pas perdu notre temps cette
expérience nous montre que ça va être
difficile et c'est aussi mon
appréciation personnelle à moi mais je
pense que au bout d'un certain temps
si on gère bien la situation et
est sous l'autorité du président on a
appris à faire cela donc c'est une
tension qui
qui disent on vibre au tour dans notre
pays mais qui au bout d'un moment on va
redescendre par rapidement pas
immédiatement mais l'histoire de
l'humanité est telle que cette situation
fait que un jour ou l'autre les gens
sont fatigués et ils ne demanderont de
revenir à une discussion à des
négociations en matière de sécurité
collective et stratégique
comme boulgakov l'avait dit dans son
chef-d'oeuvre
faut pas réclamer la venue des ans les
gens viennent d'eux-mêmes ici c'était la
situation 2008 2009
ils sont venus eux-mêmes et c'est eux
mêmes qui sont venus proposer de
restaurer la
coopération sur tous les plans parce que
la russie pour la communauté
internationale pour nos amis pour les
états unis pour l'union européenne est
bien plus importante que le cren et tout
le monde le sait très bien et les
ukrainiens le savent très bien aussi
et bien entendu
on va éviter les anglais s'y met
les lois du genre sont elles que au bout
d'un certain temps
la situation
liée à la reconnaissance de ces
territoires va refroidir
c'est l'expérience du passé qui nous le
montre je voudrais aussi noté
aujourd'hui une chose qu'on a évoqué des
chiens c'est une chose élémentaire qui
est très importante sur les territoires
de ces deux entités non reconnu on a
environ 800 mille citoyens de la
fédération de russie
je parle pas même du monde russes donc
qu'on qu'on soutient mais là ce sont
simplement des citoyens
russes qui vivent dans un autre pays
ce sont nos compatriotes
c'est pas simplement des gens qui
parlent le russe se sont non concitoyens
des citoyens de notre pays et c'est
évident que ans au cas où apparaissent
des problèmes par exemple quand il ya
des
camps des citoyens américains sont
l'objet son prisonnier quelque part les
autorités américaines interviennent
donc ici comme
en tant que membre du conseil de
sécurité nous ne pouvons pas ignorer
cette question donc à mon avis
si la situation
évolue
selon ce scénario
et qu'il n'y a pas d'amélioration
je pense que la seule solution
sera justement de reconnaître le statut
de ces territoires
et cela relève des compétences du
président du pays
mais sur les éléments que nous avons
cette situation
ne va probablement pas s'améliorer
monsieur poutine nous en avions parlé
vous avez vous l'avez dit c'est
important que
les
cette humeur soient partagées par les
citoyens de notre pays
et dans la mesure où nous vivons tous
dans cette même maison et qu'il ya de
grands processus est une composante
militaire mais
autant que je si je comprends bien la
majorité des habitants de nos pays
soutiendrait une telle mesure je vous
remercie je vous remercie
monsieur de médée fera c'est vous
je m'adresse à tous ici chacun d'entre
vous c'est
je le souligne spécialement
je
n'ai discuté de rien à l'avance avec
aucun d'entre vous votre avis je ne
voulais pas demander au préalable
et ce qui se passe maintenant
c'est
qu'on dit on pas d'une feuille blanche
parce que je veux connaître votre avis
sans
sans préparation particulière et cela me
paraît très important et je vous demande
par conséquent de vous exprimer je
demande au président de la douma de
prendre la parole
monsieur le président chers collègues
la douma a pris une décision nous sommes
adressés à vous cette décision n'était
pas spontanée
elle a été étudiée
nous avons proposé différentes
différentes
versions mais 351 députés ont décidé
d'adresser cette
d'adopter cette disposition de
reconnaître les républiques populaires
de donetsk est lougansk et
on a
décidé
d'envoyer un projet de d'arrêter au
ministère des affaires étrangères nous
constatons que la situation est critique
dans ces deux territoires et notre
décision weill est avant tout à
respecter des considérations
humanitaires dans la mesure où il ya des
gens qui meurent cela ne cesse pas les
députés ont considéré que kiev
cherche et intentionnellement à saboter
les accords de minsk et cela est
inacceptable et nous avons décidé
que ce sont nos concitoyens qui vivent
sur place
le nombre de demandes de nationalité
russe
c'est un million deux cent mille pour
l'instant huit cent mille en ont reçu
mais ya beaucoup plus de gens qui vivent
là ici donc il s'agit en premier lieu de
la protection de citoyens de notre pays
de nos concitoyens et nous considérons
aussi que la situation depuis huit ans
n'évolue pas et je dirais que
malgré l'hérault l'implication de
représentants d'autres pays les
autorités de kiev sabote tous les
accords toutes les obligations
précédente et monsieur le président nous
vous demandons de
considérer cette résolution de là demain
monsieur le président chers collègues
depuis sept ans nous voyons sous nos
yeux au centre de l'europe une
catastrophe humanitaire qui se déroule
durant toutes ces années
on a vraiment génocide un blocus
le non paiement d'allocations sociales
des tirs des bombardements
et ça fait plus de sept ans que la
russie
à tous les niveaux c'est toujours pro
proposé de participer à des discussions
sur la résolution
pour mettre fin à cette guerre civile à
toutes les tribunes qu'il s'agisse de la
ligne parlementaires
mais aussi sur les autres nous on ne
nous écoute pas on fait semblant il ya
un semblant de respect des accords de
même un nombre incalculable de réunion
du groupe de contact tout à fait inutile
et on voit tout à fait que le régime de
marionnettes de kiev non seulement ne
veux pas mais ne peut rien décider il a
suffit simplement que monsieur byden
bouge le toit de fait le doigt le doigt
et le procureur général d'ukraine a
sauté donc si vous voulez vraiment la
résolution ceux de ce conflit il aurait
tout de suite donné l'ordre à kiev et
tout de suite les autorités de kiev se
serait mise à la à table et aurait
résolu
aurait rempli leurs obligations de minsk
on a une dégradation de la situation
sociale est conne économique qui est
évidemment attribué à la guerre
mais c'est un projet occidentaux
occidentales anti russie où le cren ne
veuille pas ses propres intérêts mais
joue un jeu et c'est pour ça que les
accords de minsk ne sont pas
les exécuter
les
habitants de donner de l'eau va sauter
propos m'ont été traitée de terroriste
ils ont demandé
le droit de parler russe la langue leur
langue maternelle est d'avoir une
autonomie économie c'est une
revendication tout à fait nos logiques
qui est tout à fait respecté dans les
pays européens et au sud au lieu de ça
et il y a eu deux tentatives de conquête
militaire avec un grand nombre de
victimes
une aide
une catastrophe humanitaire a été
organisée où elle est ici
où sont les pays garant qui avait signé
avant le coup d'état les accords avec
l'opposition c'est à dire la grande
bretagne la france l'allemagne aucun de
ces pays n'a fait une tentative de
respecter la formule de steinmeier qui
semblait très bien c'est un document
assez simple qui était facile à mettre
en oeuvre pour le cren c'est un
territoire pour la russie ce sont des
gens
se sont fait une population qu'elles
soient russes ukrainiennes ces
populations qui parle russe et on voit
que les pays occidentaux cherchent à
faire en sorte que deux pays frères
slave s'affrontent mais les habitants de
donetsk est lougansk se sont trouvés aux
tâches de ce projet anti russe combien
de temps va-t-on encore discuté combien
de temps va-t-on encore expliqué il faut
prendre finalement une décision
suffisamment de patience a été de
descente et on a suffisamment demande et
a le crâne de respecter ces accords
d'autres on a suivi la voie diplomatique
on voit que ça ne rentre pas dans leur
projet ils ne le veulent pas il faut
appeler les choses par leur nom est ce
que les habitants de notre quête de
lougansk se sont levés contre le coup
d'état sanglant
anticonstitutionnelle
il devait y avoir une il ya une loi à la
rada qui interdisent l usage du russe et
nos partenaires occidentaux me disais
qu'il fallait que nous respections un
ces accords
qui d'ailleurs ont été validés par le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu au lieu de
forcer les autorités de de kiev à
respecter ces accords il nous désigne
ils nous accusent de tous les maux pour
nous forcer à la paix
au lieu de cela
ils
mènent une campagne militaire ces pays
occidentaux il en voit de plus en plus
d'armements d'armement notamment
offensif sans réfléchir au fait que des
nationalistes partisans de bandeira
peuvent parvenir au pouvoir demain par
exemple difficile de les appeler
autrement et qu'ils se serviront de ses
armements est-ce que cela va apporter de
la stabilité en europe est-ce que cela
va assurer un bon développement stable
et durable en europe et il me semble que
nous avons un devoir moral en russie
je ne peux pas supporter de voir tout ça
on voit des braves dames des des
vieillarde
les petits enfants qui vivent dans
des caves et toute la communauté
internationale ferme les yeux devant ça
c'est insupportable et les valeurs
européennes ont peu plus en parler après
ça c'est inhumain c'est amoral et encore
une fois
on ne peut pas consentir à tout cela il
faut prendre une décision si on
reconnaît les républiques populaires de
donetsk est lougansk si la
reconnaissance permet de de d'arranger
la situation alors elle moment il faut
faire évidemment les sanctions c'est
désagréable mais on nous qualifie
d'agresseurs nous n'avons jamais
prononcé de sanction contre le crime
nous continuons à le rapporter 2,2 alors
exporter de l'électricité de l'énergie
du gaz et beaucoup d'autres types de
produits
par conséquent je pense que l'heure est
venue il ne faut pas reporter il faut
prendre une décision
encore quelques mots je peux être sur un
ton émotionnel mais depuis
trente ans que le l'ukraine la russie
sont deux pays du vin qu'est ce que la
russie a fait de mal à le cren qu'est ce
qu'elle a fait de mal pendant cette
période du gaz presque pratiquons ap on
n'a pas fait d'ingérence contrairement
aux américains qui ont dépensé 5
milliards de dollars pour assurer un
changement du pouvoir
et il avait élu iouchtchenko après un
troisième tour où n'a pas on n'est pas
intervenu dans cette élection
tout pendant toute ces pans dans tous
ses 30 ans il n'y a jamais eu à l'ordre
du jour
une
une aide pour la crimée et sébastopol
oui il y avait 200 ans catherine deux
avaient
inclus la crimée élèves et sébastopol
dans la rue si ça fait plus de deux
cents ans que healy à la faute de la
fête de la fleur noire c'est même
peut-être plus ancien que certains pays
qui existent dans le monde nous n'avons
jamais soulever ce problème
nous avons nous avons vu ses partisans
de bandeira agir et c'est
l'exécution de policiers sur le maïdan
ces gens brûlés vifs à odessa tout cela
et c'est des petites fleurs par rapport
à tout le reste quand on voit ce qu'ils
voulaient faire en crimée est à
sébastopol et donc la russie a soutenu
le choix des habitants de crimes et de
sébastopol
conformément aux statuts de la charte de
l'onu c'est à dire le droit des peuples
à l'autodétermination
s'il ya une décision
du tribunal international
on connaît ses décisions oui il voulait
qu à la place du drapeau de la flotte
russe de la mer noire
ils voulaient qui est le drapeau de
l'otan mais nous n'avons pas le droit
moral d'admettre cela et ce thème est
aujourd'hui cette question est close
et je suppose qu'ils aient le temps est
venu de prendre une décision
continuer à discuter à faire semblant de
respecter les accords est à mort je vous
remercie
c'est platon avec j'avoue nicolas
monsieur le président chers collègues
la question que nous discutons
aujourd'hui est d'une très grande
actualité et je voudrais simplement
ajouter quelques points sur cette
thématique les états unis d'amérique
ont
transmis des documents de émis quelques
documents ou la russie comme la chine
sont traités d'ennemis et ce travail
donc nous définit comme
ennemi quand nous disons que nous avons
des négociations avec l'otan avec
l'ouest
avec l'union européenne avec les
dirigeants des pays européens
il faut avoir des discussions mais et
tout le monde nous dit qu'il faut avoir
des discussions avec
washington parce que ce sont les états
unis qui décide comment les autres
agissent et loi ce et l'union européenne
c'est pareil et donc ici que le
principal négociateur avec lesquels il
faut discuter ce sont des états unis
regardez monsieur la voix off disent
qu'ils veulent organiser encore une une
réunion entre le président mbaye du
président poutine quels seront le sujet
ils ne le disent pas simplement se
rencontrer pour parler
pour
dire que nous sommes en dialogue etc
et nous avons probablement pas besoin de
discussion mais obtenir parvenir à des
objectifs concrets leur objectif ils les
cachent mais c'est l'effondrement de la
fédération de russie notre objectif
c'est de défendre l'intégrité
territoriale et la souveraineté
nationales d'autres notre pays en ce qui
concerne le conflit en ukraine
et ce qui s'y passe
nous sommes convaincus ce n'est pas le
peuple ukrainien qui organise et cela le
peuple ukrainien était contre et il a
été intimidés ils étaient forcés à
suivre cette voie ce sont les états unis
qui organise et cela de même qu'ils
avaient le conflit avec la géorgie en
2008 quand la décision a a été prise à
l'époque et donc nous voyons que ce sont
avec les états unis qu'il faut parler en
ce qui concerne les républiques
populaires de donetsk est lougansk
le peuple la population a tellement
souffert depuis huit ans on ne peut plus
supporter et donc je pense que la
décision qu'on pourrait prendre au
soleil tout à fait légitime et nous
devons soutenir la décision que le dôme
à vous recommander à vous président
et je pense que si nous le faisons
nous protégerons ces gens qui vivent sur
ce territoire nous devons nous
préoccuper de cette question et nous
devons leur donner la possibilité de
travailler tranquillement mais je le
répète ce qui se passe c'est un des
conflits locaux qui ont été organisées
par les états unis
et donc je propose
il me paraît intéressant de répondre à
la proposition américaine de monsieur
baden pour que vous y des discussions
avec lui pendant lesquelles vous
pourriez le dire que
que tout ce qui a été fait contre le
peuple 2
des répliques populaire de données est
lougansk nous sommes obligés de les
soutenir si vous êtes capable à
un délai très court 2 3 jours c'est
c'est tout
tout ce massacre à ce moment là nous
mènerons un dialogue et elles sont
mollahs le peuple se développera et
pourra réaliser
ils n'ont pas un
ordre du jour mais les accords de mise
pour que cela soit fait à court terme et
je suis convaincu que vous aurez une
réponse négative ils ne seront pas
d'accord avec vous est alors la seule
solution est bien c'est de reconnaître
je vous remercie
monsieur le président
sur membres du conseil de sécurité ça
fait plusieurs mois que nous travaillons
sur une éventuelle réaction consistant à
reconnaître et les républiques
populaires sur la base d'une analyse des
risques
auxquels nous serions confrontés si nous
admettions reconnaissions ces
républiques donc un travail a été fait
en profondeur
ya la question de des restrictions d'un
vin
d'importation d'un certain nombre de
produits de haute technologie et donc il
ya eu le mystère des finances qui a
opposé un certain nombre de solutions au
cas où nous prendre de telles décisions
pour réagir et notamment avec la banque
centrale et pour nous il est évident que
dans la mesure où la situation va
continuer à se dégrader ça paraît
évident la perte de tempo de pour la
russie n'est pas possible donc il faut
réagir cette situation il faut se
mobiliser il ya cette question de la
substitution des importations et de
politiques de développement pour notre
pays et nous prendrons toutes les
mesures nécessaires pour assurer ce te
croissance économique volant jones
jeudi réussie
j'ai écouté ce que monsieur patrushev
viens te lire évidemment il faut
systématiser notre position et
effectivement comme il l'a dit s'il n'y
a pas de réaction du côté américain ce
moment-là assumer notre position
ensuite
monsieur narychkine
monsieur le président
depuis un moment déjà ceux dont nous
discutons je vous informe régulièrement
que les autorités de kiev n'ont pas
l'intention de remplir les accords 2000
ce que le président est chrétien et son
milieu
dit
publiquement toutes sortes de choses sur
les accords de minsk il dit que qui dit
attaché mais dans la réalité il n'a pas
du tout l'intention de les mettre en
oeuvre c'est la même chose dans des
discussions avec les partenaires
occidentaux
si à ces discussions on sait qu'il ya
pas de presse il le dit directement que
les accords de minsk ne seront pas mises
en oeuvre nous ne pouvons pas nous ne
voulons pas pour les autorités de kiev
le pouvoir est plus important que la
paix que la restauration de la paix et
la liquidation de ce conflit
entre le régime de kiev
et le donne basse
alors sur l'évolution de la situation en
ukraine je peux dire que si une thèse
particulièrement complexe
dans les autorités toucher les autorités
russes
qui étaient nés
dans le
département d'état américain et ce plan
qui comprend évidemment une agression
contre une guerre contre le kr est né
selon consiste à dire
cela l'objectif est de provoquer le
régime de kiev a tenté de résoudre le
problème du dôme basse par la voix mais
l'état est évidemment cela nous n'avons
pas le droit de le permettre comme cela
a été dit il y a ils sont 4 millions au
moins qui vivent sur place qu'ils
veulent
par les pensées en ruche qui veulent
honorer leur histoire je n'avais les
héros de l'histoire qui ont défendu
cette terre pendant de longues années
et si on se souvient de l'attitude de la
russie
il ya sept ou huit ans
quand elle a réagi
à la volonté de la population de crimes
et de sébastopol vivre au sein de la
fédération de russie et d'ailleurs
c'était
ses habitants de crimée et de
sébastopol l'avait exprimé dans la
procédure la plus démocratique qui soit
c'est à dire un référendum populaire et
je considère que
dans la situation actuelle nous devons
agir de la même façon je serais d'accord
avec eux la proposition de ce patron
chef
pour que
nous disions à nos partenaires
occidentaux
nous donnent leur donnions une dernière
chance
leur proposer à très court terme de
force et kiev à faire la paix et à
remplir les accords de minsk autrement
nous devons prendre la décision que nous
avons que nous parlons aux journaux
autrement vous voulez lancer des
négociations
ou
reconnaître la souveraineté
dites-le franchement je soutiens la
décision de reconnaître
je soutiendrai où je soutiens je
soutiens
la proposition
de
d'inclure les républiques de donetsk est
lougansk la fédération dossier non non
non on parle pas de ça aujourd'hui on
parle de la reconnaissance de leur
indépendance
oui je soutiens la proposition de
soutenir leur indépendance
monsieur le président chers collègues on
peut trouver toujours trouvé dans
l'histoire des situations similaires à
tel ou tel qu'un
et quand on voit les déclarations des
autorités de kiev qui elle disait que
vous êtes obligé dans cette situation de
de signer les accords de minsk parce
qu'ils avaient été les forces et c'était
comme un acte de capitulation mes
collègues entre guillemets fait une
analogie avec l'histoire rappelez-vous
mai 1945 l'allemagne certes le signe
l'acte de
capitulation et finalement ne remplit
pas le document qu'elle a signés parce
qu'il y avait des difficultés quelles
que soient ses difficultés
il y avait peut-être des des feux dans
l'est des tirs dans les rues de berlin
mais c'est pas une réponse donc quand
les partenaires occidentaux vous invite
à jouer à ce jeu honnête des
négociations à ce moment là un peu de
jus on ne peut jouer ce jeu honnêtement
c'est que si les cartes sont claires
pour tout le monde il faut pas chercher
à dire que les cartes sont de mauvaise
qualité et cetera
il faut
de quoi peut-on parler dans ces
conditions
personne nous appellent à discuter mais
on
ce sont ses partenaires qui nous ont
présentés d'une petite fiole d'avec
d'une arme de destruction massive qui
ont bombardé l'irak qui ont bombardé
d'autres pays ce qui nous appellent au
dialogue et donc je pense qu évidemment
il faut le reconnaître
le statut de ces républiques populaires
de donetsk est lougansk dans les limites
administratives que ces
peuples que le cc république et ses
territoires et leurs populations étaient
avant ce conflit est respectée les les
limites et les frontières historiques en
ce qui concerne le
le négociations comme l'a dit votre
collègue nous sommes dans l'impasse a
fait huit ans qu'on négocie
donc tous les représentants
permanents
vous allez parler de votre position
personnelle et nous considérons que vos
collègues seront d'accord s'il est
nécessaire parmi vous de donner une
autre un autre avis vous pourrez le
faire bien atteint
ce chèque relève
aujourd'hui nous nous souvenons tous
évidemment l'année 2014 et avec quelle
douleur notre peuple avait pris cette
décision et ce qui s'est passé en crimée
dans le donbass et ne nous souvenons de
la demande dans l'opinion publique de
reconnaissance déjà à l'époque et nous
comprenons le courage qu'il a fallu aux
autorités de notre pays pour laisser aux
autorités de kiev de soigner elle même
cette blessure qu'il y avait sur le
corps de l'ukraine
de ce peuple qui est un seul peuple avec
nous
donc c'est ça fait déjà maintenant
deuxième président qui
est en poste ici et le président
précédent est aujourd'hui poursuivi pour
avoir signé les accords de minsk ont
joie on voit aujourd'hui ses nazis au
pouvoir en ukraine et on imagine que si
les autorités les autorités ukrainiennes
reviennent en force dans le don de basse
on voit très bien ce qui peut se passer
et aujourd'hui
il y à un groupement de force qui fait
un groupe armé qui est tout à fait
comparable avec ce qu'avait fait
goût derian
en 1945 dans le donbass
et en plus de ça on accuse la russie
d'agressivité
alors qu'elle ne fait que défendre la
vie de ses confrères je pense que nous
devons reconnaître donetsk est lougansk
je vous remercie je m'adresse à tous les
potes toutes les personnes présentes ici
si quelqu'un d'autre point de vue ou un
une opinion particulière sur cette
question je vous prie de prendre la
parole
non
alors je connais la position du
ministère des affaires étrangères celles
du ministère de la défense du fsb mais
je voudrais demander à monsieur lavrov
de reprendre la parole
donc ici les tous les arguments en
faveur de cette décision
quelle que soit la décision d'hier
hexion nous regardons nous voyons que
les pays occidentaux
exécute un plan qui va à l'encontre des
accords de minsk et les autorités de
kiev vont dans la même direction et cela
ne veut absolument pas dans le sens d'un
règlement du conflit et c'est le seul
conflit ou une des parties refusent de
discuter avec l'autre et cela est
complètement soutenu par les pays
occidentaux c'est le conflit reprenait
d'autres cas comme le conflit de chypre
il ya un processus de négociations
l'onu est intermedia prenez le mal et où
les français ont eu beaucoup de
problèmes avec le président y ait des
discussions en ethiopie séparé de
belgrade pristina il ya un dialogue
qui sous l'égide de l'union européenne
que tout le monde cherche à aider mais
ici je vois aussi un autre aspect qui a
été évoqué par vous lors de la presse
confondent la conférence de presse avec
monsieur le chancelier choles
tout seul canton le génocide et il était
léa aux bombardements américains en
serbie contre eux
l'avis de l'onu et là on a aussi
des partisans en néo nazis de bandeira
qui
cherche à faire un génocide et dans les
deux cas on a ici une manifestation
c'est quelque chose qui va contre les
slaves contre les
les orthodoxes contre tout ce qui est
russe
nous connaissons la constitution
ukrainienne mais ne sommes nous savons
que ils ne servent ils ne cessent de
prendre d'adopter des lois qui vont dans
le sens de durcissement contre l'emploi
du russe
dans la vie commune et par cela je pense
que nous pourrions donner un signe très
fort au monde russes nous ne pouvons pas
regarder
continuer à regarder depuis 28 ans
les brimades dont font l'objet nos
concitoyens je ne vois pas d'autre
solution
en ce qui concerne la proposition
de donner encore deux ou trois jours aux
pays occidentaux pour réfléchir c'est
une question en se disant déçu et pas
des goûts et des couleurs mais je pense
pas que l'occident change
fondamentalement de position je vous
remercie
monsieur le président on est en 2022 et
ça fait huit ans que les gens là bas se
sont habitués à vivre dans des caves des
petits enfants jusqu'aux grands
alors il ya un des points qui n'a pas
été
alors il ya un point qui a été respectée
dans les accords c'est quand il ya eu le
retraite désormais encore il était
respecté
parce que l'ukraine
espérait qu' un jour il pourrait
légaliser cette situation de façon
militaire la page suivante de ce livre
c'est le renforcement de l'armée
ukrainienne ce renforcement se poursuit
avec des objectifs qui ne sont pas
claires des missions qui ne sont pas
claires
il ya ici beaucoup de considération
et
et on voit une obstination
ici
mais on voit que tous les jours
on voit deux ou trois huit de deux trois
quatre voire huit vols d'armement qui
arrive à kiev en provenance des pays
occidentaux on nous dit que ce sont des
armes défensives
comme le fameux javelin on nous dit que
c'est une arme défensive
et il ya aujourd'hui plus de soldats de
l'otan que dans certains pays de l'otan
et en même temps on nous dit que
personne ne veut respecter les accords
de minsk
donc dans cette situation je considère
qu' on ne nous l'a cela ne nous a pas
laissé le choix et moi je dis oui il
faut reconnaître donetsk est lougansk
monsieur le président depuis plusieurs
années
logan ce qu'est donetsk
font que certains de leurs
citoyens ne cesse de regarder la russie
pour lui demander de l'aide
ils veulent vivre travailler et élever
leurs enfants vivre dans la paix et je
suis absolument convaincu qu'il est
nécessaire de mettre en oeuvre leurs
droits et de les protéger et qu il faut
prendre une décision
pour
de reconnaître leur indépendance et cela
est important pour eux
monsieur le président
le chancelier allemand a dit que les
discussions
sur un génocide dans le donbass le
faisait rien imaginons si c'était des
habitants à lui des citoyen allemand qui
vivait sur place et qui auraient été
victimes des bombardements comment
aurait-il beige et monsieur macron vous
avez parlé avec lui il a dit
que les autorités de minsk était prête à
respecter les accords de main et les
collègues vendus aujourd'hui ils disent
eux-mêmes que non et monsieur jeunes ce
qui le dit lui même qu'il est prêt à
créer un arsenal nucléaire en
alors eux ils n'ont pas de frontières
avec patience et les américains qui sont
les patrons et pour eux c'est tous la
même chose des tous et toutes ces armes
qui sont brandis par tous tout cela il
faut fait qu' il faut reconnaître les
républiques de donetsk woods et je pense
qu'il faut continuer à aller plus loin
j'ai dit tout ce que je pensais je vous
remercie chers collègues
j'ai entendu votre avis
il y aura une décision qui sera prise
aujourd'hui je tiens à vous remercier
pour cette discussion